and you know i'm going to make cars
electric so we don't have to depend on
fossil fuels and i'm going to get us to
mars
so we're interplanetary species and i'm
going to do neural link so that our
brain
can control you know you know our brain
can download information and upload
information
but he was talking about he was like
yeah like warren buffett
um like he's like i'm not a huge fan of
the guy not the biggest fan but he
didn't say he disliked him but he was
like
you know what he does he's a capital
allocator like he spends his time trying
to figure out do i buy
pepsi yeah it's so
that's boring to me like i want to
change the world
and you know i'm going to make cars
electric so we don't have to depend on
fossil fuels and i'm going to get us to
mars
so we're interplanetary species and i'm
going to do neural link
so that our brain can control you know
you know our brain can download
information and upload information
like we're a computer and a brain and
i'm going to do boring company because i
hate traffic
and i want to get you know from place to
place in you know
15 minutes rather than two hours and i'm
like okay you know respect like when you
hear that
you're like yeah that does seem like the
maximum of winning
um but you know i guess my view is
it my views are broadened but i'm like
you where i when i hear myself say it
i'm like
don't be a dude just like come on
go for it don't
do what you would do at the beginning
you know like
don't don't lose that sort of uh dream
um
just because of practicality